Overlord has arrived director Julius
Avery's mashup of drama at the turning
point of World War two and Nazi science
experiments straight out of Wolfenstein
is finally here riding a strong wave of
critical buzz as it lands in theaters
for viewers eager for a little pulpy
period horror how deep do those Nazi
experiments go let's find out as we
dissect the ending of overlord spoilers
ahead obviously it's a minefield out
there before our reluctant heroes from
the US Army even get a whiff of what's
going on in the lab beneath the villages
Church they enter the home of Chloe who
lives with what she describes as a very
sick aunt we figure out what's up pretty
quickly and the Chloe confirms that the
illness is actually the result of
experimentation done by the Nazis at the
church then the action picks up and the
aunts illness has barely mentioned again
while our heroes are busy blowing up the
lab though it's hard not to wonder how
many people did the narcy's experiments
on only to release back to their homes
at some points how many of them are
there and how far back does that trail
stretch even if the lab itself has gone
the victims aren't and it seems likely
that someone from the Allied forces will
find them as boys and his compatriots
dig further into what's really going on
beneath the church they discover that
the mysterious experiments are all based
on a substance that occurs underground
naturally
somehow having the capability to
reanimate dead bodies and supercharge
live ones if properly refined
what is this the Nazis haven't perfected
the process yet but the serum clearly
has some powerful effects and they seem
to have a constant supply by the end of
the film the lab is gone but if the
zombie making tar was there all along
isn't it possible that there's a good
deal more of it down there what's so
special about this particular place if
this much progress has been made in this
one french village it's likely that
other Nazis are aware of the tiles
capabilities and they're already looking
for more elsewhere in Europe and there
may well be more out there the lab might
be destroyed but the search for the
substance I can grant a thousand-year
Reich is definitely not it's clear from
what little we know of the Nazis actual
scientific process that there's been a
lot of trial and error involved in this
serum they're developing and we don't
actually know how they realize they
could use a tar beneath the church for
that purpose in the first place
Overlord is a film that plays on reports
of secret Nazi programs geared towards
all sorts of occult things so the film
can get away with a lot this atmosphere
plus the strange dead animal the
soldiers discover in the woods hints
that there were definitely experiments
of a different kind in this village
before the serum was developed was the
doctor up to some kind of gene splicing
was he trying to create hybrid war dogs
of some kind we don't know but the Nazis
sloppy operation implies that there's
more to be found out there than just
human zombies Overlord takes as many
genre liberties as at once
but it also follows certain war movie
structural conventions and perhaps
nowhere is that more evident than in the
story of Chloe and her little brother
Paul who bond with the soldiers after
they holed up in their house a romantic
connection between boys and Chloe is
heavily implied what happens now do the
soldiers just move on and leave these
two to be build their lives they might
be separated temporarily but the bonding
experience of the mission and boys his
sensitive soul makes them being apart
permanently seem unlikely he might march
on to Berlin sure but we feel like he'll
be back eventually to get to know the
French girl a little better at the
beginning of overlord Ford is the rough
cynical officer who's been through hell
and isn't about to go soft for anyone
while boys is the innocent young trainee
who's terrified of war and once proved
himself too sensitive to even kill a
mouse by the end of the film
Ford is dead and boys
absorbed many of his lessons he's
capable of killing a thinking on his
feet and winning in a hard fights even
if much of his innocence and compassion
have been preserved we get the sense of
boys isn't likely to just leave chloe in
the village forever but what about the
rest of his military career if the film
adheres to the same World War two
timeline as the real world then boys
still has nearly a year of fighting left
to do and then he might be left in
Europe to clean up after the Nazis when
Germany surrenders he's had experience
with the supernatural now even if he's
not telling anyone about it will he just
leave that in his past or will he be
keeping an eye open for other Nazi
facilities like the one beneath the
church ready to strike as necessary
we're betting on the latter